bonsoir à tous c'est une grande première
pour moi donc
comme toutes les premières fois je fais
un intérieur je me présente je m'appelle
lee - christian j'ai 42 ans
je suis un passionné de biologie
d'entrepreneuriat et surtout passionné
j'aime apprendre
lorsqu'on m'a parlé de la thématique
orthodoxe la suite logique pour moi
était de sortir du cadre à sortir du
cadre sorties ont des conventions
sortions du système actuel sortir de nos
habitudes et sortir du card c'est aller
vers de quelque chose soit qu'un enfant
quand encore exploré sortir du card
l'ailier tout de suite à la notion aussi
d'entrepreneuriat
comment on peut créer une entreprise
aujourd'hui comme on peut innover tout
en reste tout en sortant du cadre
d'où l'idée de se dire comment on peut
créer une entreprise qui lierait
consommation et développement durable
on va d'abord abordé la notion de
consommation c'est quoi la consommation
la consommation
c'est utiliser un bien ou service à la
détruire et cette utilisation
provoque une destruction totale ou
partielle donc là on voit bien qu'on est
linéaire une société dite de
consommation lorsque tous les acteurs se
mettre en ordre pour que cette
consommation soit abondante ces acteurs
sur la publicité
ca les crazy la nouveauté
l'obsolescence programmée donc tout le
monde s'est mis d'accord pour que ça
consomme donc là on est toujours dans
cette notion de linéarité et on va on va
en plus on consomme on consomme et
durable ça veut dire quoi durable me
dira ça veut dire pérenne ça veut dire
quelque chose qui dure dans le temps
allez développement durable qu'est ce
que ça veut dire développement durable
on on utilise des ressources pour notre
besoin sans entacher sans détruire ce
qui a besoin pour nos pour les
générations futures
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui on va
utiliser des éléments va lui créer des
choses mais qui vont permettre quand
même aux générations futures de pouvoir
subsister
donc là on se dit
ok on a deux notions qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec ça est ce que ces notions
est-ce qu'on peut les compléter à ce que
ça peut fonctionner bonzi bas alors
elles seront pas gaulliste
ça veut dire qu'une consommation peut
pas être durable si on peut essayer on
peut se dire lequel comment on peut
imaginer
justement cette liaison entre ces deux
éléments parce qu'il faut bien qu'on
vive faut bien qu'on soit si on imagine
un monde dans lequel où on dirait
consommation développement durable on
serait quand même relativement loin du
cadre et du coup comment sortir de ce
cadre
pourquoi pourquoi changer en fait
pourquoi changer les choses
pourquoi on peut qu'on continuerait pas
comme ça après tout c'est notre vie les
autres on verra après on peut se poser
cette question on peut dire ça je vous
dis aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui a fait que
j'ai changé
qu'est-ce qui a fait que mes motivations
sont aussi fortes pour lier ces deux
concepts et qu'est ce qui a fait
aujourd'hui qu'on peut se dire que c'est
possible de le faire
premièrement c'est la notion une notion
de vitesse je me demandais quelques
secondes de réfléchir dans les cinq
dernières années
qu'est ce que vous avez trouvé qui a été
hyper vite dans son évolution
sympa technologique ça patine
disparition d'espèces ça peut être ce
que vous voulez on voit que les choses
s'accélèrent d'autant plus on est à
l'échelle d'une
d'une vie dans une demie vie d'homme
même on est à l'échelle de cinq ans on
parle pas de chose de nouveau parents
qui eux ne disait de notre temps c'était
comme ça il y avait ça rsa aujourd'hui
on parle de deux phénomènes de cette
vitesse de l'évolution de notre société
qui vont ça va hyper vite on n'a jamais
eu autant de personnes
en peu d'années qui se sont expertisés
sur les notions de développement durable
tout le monde fait soi même ses gâteaux
tout le monde fait soin de son yaourt
pour ceux qui le font on devient aussi
experts pensent eux formant avec
l'arrivée d'internet on appuie ce fort
mais on a on a accès à la connaissance
on peut tout apprendre sur tous les
sujets donc ça va très très vite
on est à l'échelle d'un an deux ans
trois ans et quel sera l'avenir pour
plus tard un deuxième élément qui m'a
fortement motivés et qui aujourd'hui est
vraiment le moteur en fait ce qui m'a
vraiment pris aux tripes me dire ok
qu'est ce qu'on fait pourquoi on va
pourquoi je ne pas laisser les choses
comme ça on a vu que cette vitesse était
importante et aussi sur cette vitesse
elle a aussi du bon comme je vous ai dit
on a réussi à avancer les esprits ont
avancé mais très vite elle vient très
vite on a eu des associations de
protection environnement qu'ils soient
qui se sont multipliés et vraiment
spécialisés sur des sujets donc cette
vitesse utilisons là donc on la regarde
deux côtés deuxième élément le 20
décembre 2017 et la naissance de ma
fille
donc le fait d'être pas parce avons
rempli plein d'émotions vous dites ok
j'ai la responsabilité
après il n'y a pas de choses qui
reviennent aux souvenirs d'enfance on
dit quand j'étais petit j'étais comme ça
j'étais comme ça j'étais comme ça je
suis né sur et la martinique
et lorsqu'on vit sur une île qui aussi
belle que celle de la réunion le monde
il d'adoption on a une relation
particulière avec notre environnement
c'est à dire on est connecté
on va chercher des fruits on a un petit
bout de jardin on a des choses en la
cour voilà aînés vous il ya des choses
où on a une connexion à la plage on voit
des animaux on voit des choses mais se
dire l'idée m'a traversé l'esprit se
dire que ma fille ne connaîtra
aujourd'hui les le monde tel qu'il est
que dans des livres ou conan des
reportages j'ai pas accepter cette idée
j'ai aussi dit non il
faire quelque chose on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui se dire je ne passe pas à
l'action
ces deux éléments m'ont motivé j'ai
aussi il ya une vitesse très forte donc
les jardins pts très vite les concepts
et pérenniser notre environnement
mais lorsqu'on prend ces deux éléments
on se dit ben comment on va faire
aujourd'hui on va entreprendre
on veut être libre on veut créer sa
propre activité on dit comment je vais
entreprendre quelles ressources jeu peu
avant qu'elle
qu'est ce que je peux utiliser pour
entreprendre qu'est-ce qui peut
m'inspirer
et qu'est-ce qui peut me permettre de
pouvoir de pouvoir créer de manière
durable
j'ai vu un ouvrage qui s'appelle
l'économie bleus de good terme paroli où
il prenait l'exemple de s'inspirer de la
nature
ça a été ma première source
d'inspiration pour créer mon acte
immonde entreprises aujourd'hui
la nature en fête c'est un niveau vert
est là allez on va dire trois milliards
d'années de recherche et développement
donc alors forcément trouver une
solution au problème qu'on a la nature à
une autre caractéristique séquelles
qu'elle fonctionne en essais et c'est
échec et sèche continue elle ne baisse
jamais les bras
il ya plein d'applications qui sont
inspirées de la nature notamment au
niveau technologique
on a les ailes des avions je sais pas si
vous avez remarqué sur les ailes des
avions on à l'extrémité qu'un petit peu
qu'un petit peu comme ça les ingénieurs
aéronautiques se sont rendus compte que
les aigles avaient l'extrémité des
rémiges qui étaient ils ont ré les
doigts comme ça qu'on stabilise et le
vol ils l'ont appliquée aux avions ils
ont fait l'économie d'énergie et
diminuer les turbulences on a aussi à
l'exemple du train au japon qui lui
avait une vraie problématique à ce que
300 colis mode km un pardon quand il
traversait les villes on avait un
on avait du bruit énormément de bruit
qui se faisaient et ils ont cherché ils
sont sont inspirés de la forme du bec du
martin pêcheur pour se dire comment je
vais faire pour diminuer ce bruit parce
que cet oiseau quand ils allaient pêcher
quand il va pêcher non en fait il ya
très peu de friction quand il arrive
dans l'eau la sodec en fait à inspirer
la forme du train du coup réduction du
bruit et la diction de 15 % de
consommation énergétique
mais la nature n'est pas que technology
and un pont aussi en terme
d'organisation en management et
organisation
si vous regardez une forêt comment elle
est constituée tout est connecté
c'est un système entre mais entre eux
mêmes on prend l'exemple d'une forêt
avec un arbre vous avez cet arbre les
feuilles les racines et en dessous des
champignons donc avec des micros
filaments l'armée le champignon
communiqué l'abandonner à l'autre que
l'autre peut pas lui apporter
mais en plus de ça comme on a plusieurs
arbres on a plusieurs champignons basse
et champignons se connecter entre eux et
on s'est rendu compte qu'il ya de
l'information qui circule d'un arbre à
l'autre
lorsqu'on a une attaque dans un majeur
sur un arbre qui en début de forêt les
arbres au milieu ont déjà là
l'information et on y prépare déjà la
réponse donc là on a le premier réseau
internet qui croyait bien avant que
l'homme y est pensé ça des sas et les
milliards d'années d'évolution
deuxième chose la nature elle est frugal
elle utilise que ce qu'elle a besoin
elle a besoin de peu de chose à utiliser
peu de choses on n'est pas hyper
consommation si on l'appliquait une
entreprise d'un fou égalité on diminue
nos coûts on essaie de d'aller vers le
cette frugalité aussi bien énergétique
consommation de matières premières et
tout ça donc on est vraiment dans cette
notion destination de nature et de se
dire comment comment on fait pour
pouvoir
innover de manière durable parce que si
vous rappelez bien je vais parler la
notion de consommation l'hypothèse de
départ c'est que les ressources est
infinie c'est à dire que chaque année je
vais acheter une nouvelle voiture chaque
année j'ai acheté un nouveau téléphone
on va aller dans l'excès monzie mais bon
pour fabriquer tous ces éléments il faut
bien des ressources et ses ressources on
a fini sur les industriels mais vous
savez bien vous s'est tous rendu compte
qu'on est sur des ressources et un film
qu'on est sûr de ressources finies donc
le biomimétisme est un outil un outil
que j'ai utilisée qui m'a permis de
créer un modèle économique basé sur
cette coopération la forêt la nature
l'écosystème lui aussi est basé aussi
sur cette coopération c'est la
coopération il n'y a pas de dominance
tout le monde s'entraide
et lorsqu'un arbre qui tombe il ya un
autre qui prend sa place sans forcément
dominer toute toute la forêt et tout le
monde a besoin de tout le monde donc ça
veut dire que vous allez sur je prends
l'exemple un marché fort à vous allez
sur un marché fort a en fait vous avez
tous les produits tout le monde
s'entraide vous y aller parce que vous
trouvez vos légumes vos fruits tout ce
que vous voulez sur la coopération
on est directement sur le producteur
donc on est on s'inspire aussi de la
nature ont fait des choses de manière
très très linéaire est très simple
ensuite il ya un deuxième
un deuxième élément qui est qui et le
traitement tue à dire souvent on crée
des entreprises on va chercher à innover
sur des thématiques qui sont pas
forcément utiles à l'homme et à
l'environnement donc supposer qu est ce
qui est réellement utile qu est ce qui
peut être important pour vous quelle
quelle douleur vous avez qu'est ce que
vous voudriez créé et est ce que la
nature pour vous inspirer
donc ce serait de se dire aujourd'hui
quelles problématiques sont réellement
utiles à l'homme quelle problématique
peut-on vraiment à explorer et qu'on
chercherait à la solution dans dans le
dans biomimétisme il y en a plein
d'exemples il ya des exemples de
coopération iliad équilibre de société
les animaux ont fait arriver à trouver
des solutions pour tous et je pense que
ce livre qui est à quai la nature ce
grand livre ouvert
il faut le lire il faut apprendre lire
apprendre à se reconnecter
si on veut garder
nos ressources parce que si demain on
n'a plus accès à cette bibliothèque
et si ces livres ont brûlé ou ont
disparu mais on ne peut pas en fait
résonant problème parce qu'on n'a pas la
r&d de la nation elle a disparu elle
n'est plus là donc ça c'est une notion
qui est assez forte et aujourd'hui en
fait on a aussi pour revenir sur le
thème de vitesse je ne sais pas si vous
vous rendez compte
à la réunion le nombre de boutiques 0
d'échecs qui existent aujourd'hui à la
réunion
ça va très vite on a plein
d'associations zéro déchet on a des tout
le monde apprend à faire les choses soi
même donc on est beaucoup dans le do it
yourself donc utiliser utilisons tout
cette mention s'utilise ont tout ce que
peut vous apporter ses 7,7 ce
bouillonnement ce foisonnement utilisons
surfant sur cette vague et disons qu
est-ce qu on peut amener chacun amène sa
pierre à l'édifice petit à petit chacun
fait son chemin
je vais vous proposer quelque chose si
vous êtes ok avec cette idée c'est se
dire comment on peut aujourd'hui innover
demain vous êtes les générations futures
vous est ce qu'ils vont aller dans la
discussion
vous êtes à l'aise avec le sujet vous
avez adopté les nouvelles technologies
mais en même temps vous êtes aussi
informer sur les effets de la de notre
hyper consommation est ce qu'aujourd'hui
un sujet que vous auriez aimé le traité
et aujourd'hui vous ne trouvez pas la
solution pour la faire de manière
durable
ce serait de se dire à l'issue de ce
tête à l'issue de cette conférence vous
rentrez chez vous vous réfléchissez vous
dis mais quel problème j'aimerais traité
casse q qu'est ce que j'aimerais faire
qu'est-ce-qui qui aujourd'hui me
permettrai de aller mieux et de d'aller
vers la création d'entreprise et se dire
qu'est ce que la nature peut m'apporter
il ya de nombreuses associations qui
sont spécialisés en biens mis les tees
il ya des organismes aussi qui
travaillent dessus tout les industriels
sans sur le sujet parce que c'est une
des clés pour qu'on puisse dans cette
aide est dans cet équilibre
vous avez votre problème vous prenez
vous allez voir la nature ce qui peut se
faire
internet est là on a accès à de
l'information n'a jamais aussi informés
et ont regardé quels types d'entreprises
vais crier vous prenez le problème
inverse vous trouvez un élément qui vous
ont inspiré la nation peut être des
abeilles qui se déplacent de telle
manière on peut dire qu'elle arrive
enfin en équilibre thermique dans la
ruche mais comment je peux faire pour
résoudre un problème pas de
climatisation dans une maison comment on
peut faire ça et les ça va et ça va
avancer se dit aujourd'hui qu'on peut
innover qu'on peut créer de la valeur
qu'on peut aussi être entrepreneur en
s'inspirant de la nature
c'est une vraie valeur ajoutée et on a
une telle richesse sur nos îles parce
que si demain on a un changement
climatique on a une montée des eaux
on va être les premières victimes ainsi
loué mon tabac sur une île on a entouré
donc forcément mécaniquement ça va être
plus compliqué si on a plus de
ressources
on va être beaucoup plus impactés donc
on est les premières victimes climatique
on sera les premiers réfugiés
climatiques on sera vraiment les
premiers des premières victimes d'un
soir les premiers innover soyez les
premiers à se dire ok on sa sphère la
nature on a une nature qui est
magnifique on a des cirques qui sont
magnifiques on a un équilibre on a des
forêts primaires
comment cet équilibre y tiens comment je
peux m'inspirer de ça et je vais créer
le
l'application de mon observation en
local se dire que ça ça va me servir le
matage et emploi de déplacement ok je me
dis qu'est-ce qu'il faut que je résous à
ce que c'est le changer de voiture
francis une voiture électrique parce que
je veux revoir mon mode de déplacement
ce que je fais du covoiturage
donc toutes ces notions profitons d'être
sur son côté atypique d'être sur une île
travaillons réfléchissons regardons
ensemble et si vraiment vous voulez
aller plus loin partager vos idées des
choses qui disons qu'ils sont venus à
l'esprit sur cette notion de
consommation durables et création
d'entreprise inspiré du biomimétisme
partagés sur la page facebook proposer
vos idées échangées entre vous soyez
acteurs de demain
créé le monde de demain faites-nous
surprenez nous innover innover innover
et penser aux générations futures
[Applaudissements]